Welcome to mCoding.
Today we're hitting a common problem with
some recursive algorithms causing them to
fail on even moderately sized inputs.
Let's say you have to traverse a tree in some
way.
The tree is made up of nodes that contain
some data and zero or more child nodes.
Let's take a dead simple recursive task, just
printing out the nodes.
Here's the whole implementation, yes it's
that simple.
We print out the current node, then loop over
the children, recursing on each child.
The order we are going in here is called a
pre-order traversal of the tree, by the way.
And it works!
When we give it this small example, it prints
out all the nodes in the expected order.
First the root, then child 0, the three children
of child 0 which are 0-0, 0-1, and 0-2, and
then child 1 of the root.
So great, all your tests pass, it's simple
and readable, you ship it to production
… and the second a client touches it, whamo
bamo it instantly breaks.
Surely they must have passed a ginormous,
unsightly, pathological tree in order to break
the perfection and elegance that is every
line of code beget of your golden fingertips?
Uhh nope, they passed a linked list with 1000
nodes in it.
What went wrong is you hit the recursion limit,
which is a mere 1000 in Python by default.
That's why the crash happens near 1000 children.
You can increase the recursion limit using
sys.setrecursionlimit but that doesn't really
solve the problem.
The recursion limit is there to fail early
in the case when you accidentally cause an
infinite recursion, so you can crash the program
instead of running out of memory and crashing
the whole computer.
Increasing the limit a lot would defeat the
purpose of having the limit.
But only increasing it a little bit is just
asking for the client to hand you a 2000 node
list in the future.
So what do we do?
We use this handy trick.
The idea is to convert your recursive call
stack into a literal call stack, making the
entire function iterative, thereby completely
bypassing any recursion limit problems.
We'll use a list as the data structure for
our stack.
Append is pushing onto the stack and pop is
popping off the stack.
We'll use a "while stack" to keep going as
long as our stack is not empty.
Then we indent this, and replace any recursive
calls like this one with pushing onto the
stack.
Running our linked list example again, we
see now it fully prints all the children down
to child 999.
But if we take a look at our first smaller
example, we'll see that we've actually changed
the order that nodes are printing in.
Before we had the root, then child 0, then
0-0, 0-1, and 0-2, finishing with child 1
last.
And the reason for that is because a stack
is a last-in-first-out data structure.
The fix for this is that in our implementation,
whenever we want to make multiple recursive
calls, we actually need to put them on the
stack in reverse order, so they go in the
intended order when we pop them off the stack.
So we just loop over each node's children
in reverse order.
Then we're back to the same output as before.
We now have an equivalent function to the
original recursive implementation that prints
our nodes and that works no matter how deep
a tree you pass it.
But you may be wondering, what if I had a
more complex recursive function that doesn't
just have a single node parameter like this
one?
Let's say I wanted to add a max depth to my
print.
In the recursive case, that means checking
if we've hit the max depth and not recursing
if we have.
Otherwise we do recurse and pass each child
one less max depth.
To make the iterative version, we do the same
trick as before, but instead of just putting
the current node on the stack, we'll put a
tuple of whatever arguments we were going
to pass to the recursive call.
We start by making a stack with the initial
arguments to the function.
Then we do a "while stack", pop off an element
from the stack, and unpack the variables.
Popping the tuple off the stack and assigning
to these variables restores all of them to
a state just like we would have had if we
made a recursive call.
Once again we indent.
An early return in the recursive implementation
just means that we don't want to do any more
work in this iteration.
So in the stack version, that just becomes
a continue, which will skip and process the
next item on the stack.
Then we replace recursive calls with just
pushing onto the stack any arguments that
we were going to pass to the recursive call.
And as before, we need to put those things
on the stack in the reverse order.
And now our max depth parameter is working.
Max depth of 0 just means printing the root.
If we have a depth of 1 then we'll use the
root and its children, but we don't recurse
to their children.
And a max depth of 2 or higher for this tree
will print the entire thing.
So that's the trick, it's just an easy way
to convert any recursive function into an
iterative one.
But I did want to finish by just pointing
out one other issue with this code.
Both the recursive and iterative solutions
still suffer from high coupling.
Namely, this function is actually doing two
things.
Number 1, it's iterating over the tree of
nodes.
And number 2, it's also operating on the data,
in this case printing out the nodes.
If we wanted to do something else besides
just print the node, we may end up copy-pasting
this entire block of code, only to change
one line.
As you can imagine, copy-pasting huge blocks
of code just to change one line is discourages.
Instead let's decouple these things by pulling
out the part that does the iteration and making
it a generator.
Instead of actually doing anything with the
node, let's just yield the node so that someone
else can do something with it.
Change the name of course.
Then we can implement our printing function
just by iterating over the nodes and printing.
Now neither the printing code nor the iteration
code needs to know anything about each other,
meaning they are completely decoupled, allowing
you to plug in a different operation or different
order of iteration without rewriting or duplicating
code.
As far as functionality goes of course it's
the same as it was before.
But especially in larger projects, this is
going to make your code much more testable
and maintainable for the future.
So just keep that in mind.
Anyway I hope you enjoyed the trick and this
video.
If you did don't forget to subscribe and if
you especially like the video please consider
becoming a patron on Patreon
So thank you so much and I'll see ya next
time.